royal est maintenant 1
je ne suis pas méchant
c
là
je vais rester tout seul on
raté
ainsi for sim plus tôt
non
lee
comment ça va ni très bien dans francine
à la mort du commandant cousteau vous
êtes retrouvé à la tête de deux
associations la cousteau society aux
états unis et l'équipe cousteau en
france et vous assurez depuis la gestion
du legs de votre mari tout en
poursuivant ses actions pour la
protection de l'environnement
alors face à cet héritage l'héritage du
commandant cousteau vous ayez la garde
du bonnet rouge oui je joue mes roues à
quand un bisou lui dit francine vous
n'êtes pas sentie contrainte finalement
quand le commandant cousteau et est mort
de poursuivre parce qu'en fait c'était
déjà votre patient depuis longtemps dans
les années soixante dix les sièges à
bénévoles des amis de la terre c'est pas
un truc nouveau et et finalement quand
vous avez rencontré le commandant
cousteau
vous étiez déjà convaincu du bien fondé
de de son action voilà alors vous l'avez
rencontré en 1976 à houston au texas
lors d'un stage de plongée à l'époque
francine vous étiez hôtesse de l'air air
france attention
naceri est parti ça tombe bien les
séries dans que les hôtesses de l'air
sent tranquille ce soir et et finalement
vous avez une liaison avec le commandant
cousteau à partir de ce moment là mais
vous êtes l air france vous y rester
jusqu'en 1992
car le commandant cousteau était marié
voilà donc que vous n'avez pas pu vous
vous montrez c'est ça non jusqu'à la
mort de sa femme vous avez été d'une
discrétion absolue vous avez sacrifié
votre vie sociale
oui c'est vrai mais enfin j'ai eu la
chance pendant pendant 15 ans d'être la
compagne d'un homme exceptionnel
je pense que je peux pas appeler ça
vraiment un sacrifice était cette carte
en w
cet homme était ravie aussi un moment
j'en prenais pas parce que tous les vols
je vais pas prendre la lufthansa air
canada t.ac.b france il est extrêmement
discrète vous avez commencé à vous voir
apparaître un peu vers 82 bon après la
disparition de sa femme il demande êtes
apparue au grand jour ce qui est normal
et en plus nous avions deux enfants donc
il était quand même temps aussi les amis
téléspectateurs c'est que cousteau tout
cousteau qu'il fût il a quand même deux
foyers quoi avec deux femmes et des
enfants dans chagny voyant la mecque
bon il a fait beaucoup de choses dans sa
vie passée tu n'as pas fait que
s'occuper des mérous apparemment ouais
mais il a fait quand même beaucoup de
choses bien bien
donc après la victoire du commandant
puisque vous avez été face à des
affaires de succession à c'est assez
terrible qui ont défrayé la chronique
la brouille avec son fils jean-michel
kaka qui a perduré
on peut pas dire que ça a été provoquée
par vous en fait je crois que la
brouille avec son fils et parce que jean
michel cousteau voulait utiliser des le
nom couche tôt pour faire des plus tôt
lui sortent dans le pacifique en
utilisant le nom pour faire des hôtels
et des clubs de vacances quoi en fait le
con longtemps a allégué à l'association
qu'il a fondée aux états unis les âges
de son nom de son image et l'ensemble de
son oeuvre
donc il souhaitait que cela soit
utilisée uniquement par cette
association
ouais et non pas par des individus donc
à des fins non commerciales voilà bien
alors vous avez eu à faire après la mort
du pardon au nom qu'elle a des yeux
sublimer les niveaux si je vais vous
laisser
que le bleu et c'est le genevois revient
de mieux même le dessus
quelles solutions ils étaient tous qui
était bleu évidemment c'est normal ça
l'intéressé alors j'avais eu à faire
après le décès du commandant cousteau à
de vrais problèmes vous était assez
courageuse d'ailleurs j'ai commencé par
liquider l'équipe américaine pourquoi
non non américains non non ça ça va être
fait par le commandant avant 81 94
s'était passé avant nous avons gardé une
équipe américaine qui est toujours là
bas d'ailleurs avec laquelle je
travaille est une équipe en france
simplement j'ai dû réduire les effectifs
activement parce qu'on est passé par une
période très difficile
justement c'est ce que voulait dire oui
c'est la réduction du nombre des
adhérents fin des contrats de production
audiovisuelle
le padd calypso deux pattes chaîne de
télévision cousteau pertes financières
obligé de déménager de changer de bureau
loyers impayés
et puis en 1999 le scandale c'est ce
touristes français en vacances au canada
qui filme un zodiac de l'équipe cousteau
qui foncent sur un groupe de rorqual
alors ça évidemment dans celle que ça
fait mauvais genre parce que voilà et
qui passent sur une baleine au moment où
elle plonge
voilà alors ça c'est ce qu'on a dit
lachance effectivement de pouvoir
démontrer que c'était quand même une
illusion d'optique
mais c'était surtout je dirais en procès
d'intention et nous avons pu démontrer
que nous n'avions rien fait de mal que
c'était un peu tout ça une pièce montée
et qu'en fait il était désagréable c'est
que nous avions l'intention de regarder
quel était l'impact des touristes sur
les 250 baleines qui viennent à cet
endroit là et bon bah ça plaisait pas à
tout le monde mais on n'avait pas
l'intention de dénoncer ou de faire un
scandale ce qu'on voulait c'était quand
même faire un état des lieux ce qui est
notre métier et je crois que bon
certains ont pris sodiac zodiac de
l'équipe cousteau bien sûr mon sushi les
baleines et les orques annie les balles
en un parcours de faire chier les mérous
et une lampe de poche la nuit pour ce
travail
c'est d'habitude j'étais dans mon lit
regardez le maire où il dort bien voilà
donc gros problème au moment où vous
avez hérité de cette succession un petit
peu difficile francine aujourd'hui
effectivement ça commence à remonter les
expéditions reprennent pour la première
fois depuis la mort du commandant
cousteau à bordeaux neil sione retour
sur la mer rouge à l'endroit où il avait
fait le monde du silence sur les traces
de la première calypso pour voir les
barrières de corail
c'est plus de l'exploration maintenance
et du bulletin de santé parce que mon
exploration été fait il ya 50 ans
aujourd'hui c'est pour voir un petit peu
un petit peu comment ça se passe et puis
aussi ça recommence à marcher
vous sortez en dvd les documentaires du
commandant cousteau en kiosque
accompagné de deux fascicules
explicatifs
en fait le public attendait depuis très
longtemps puisque les films ne passait
plus depuis quelques années le public
demandait cette série en dvd et nous
avons donc pu la faire et elle va sortir
le 18 en kiosque et enfin on pourra donc
constituer des collections ceux qui ont
aimé custeau on retrouveront ces images
et pourront les montrer à leurs enfants
leurs petits-enfants donc je pense que
la tradition continue à gérer quoi ça
ressemble